alors 2 selon vous qui est dire ah ben
je viens de le faire non c'est le fait
dans l'ordre
c'est pas de sa faute si tu bois plus
rien à ton âge
et tu sais quoi parfois de ne pas te
voir ça m'arrange selon vous
bébé c'est mon soleil selon vous à quoi
correspond ce chiffre le chiffre qu'on
va voir là peut-être
38600 euros c'est un salaire
c'est un salaire non c'est pas un
salaire
génétique
c'est une dépense un seul truc
exactement
[Musique]
anglais
alors vous êtes pas loin vous allez
halluciner c'est le cadeau qu'a fait une
star
à son fils pour ses 18 ans
38600 euros et le mot m'a trouvé ça
plutôt on revient mais ça va être génial
on revient l'interview sur pas la prison
génial on revient sur ce chiffre 38600
euros c'est un cadeau qui a été fait un
anglais un père anglais à son fils on
avance un peu et bravo
il lui offert avec sa maman pardon alors
qui se crouze quelques jours donc pour
leur 18 ans il a passé une photo sur
Instagram regardez une petite montre
elle est beau il est très belle
on dira pas la marque 38600 euros mais
bon c'est les bécanes
ou pas
dans le luxe 38000 euros c'est comme ça
ils vont pas s'empêcher de faire plaisir
à son fils parce que ça coûte 38000
euros alors Benoît moi je peux pas me
l'acheter en lui offrira jamais mais ça
me fait plaisir de ce gamin soit le
principe des parents vous qui m'écoutez
chez vous aussi et merci et mes 38000
euros mais quand il sera grand il
s'achètera des maisons à des millions et
des maisons
donner la valeur des choses s'il pense
que 38600 euros c'est un cadeau il sort
le soir il sera pas ce que c'est que 20
euros 1000 euros 1200 euros donner la
valeur des choses il y a des très belles
montres à 1000 2000 euros qui sont déjà
des très belles sommes et il y a des tas
de célébrités qui ont des montres à des
mais voilà comment créer des petits cons
des drogués des matins est-ce que tu
penses que s'il avait pas eu la montre à
30 000 €, ça lui aurait changé sa
personnalité
à tous ensemble
toi qui est toi qui a eu beaucoup
d'argent comment tu allais tes enfants
le gamin il a une montre en or qu'il est
mauvais en fait faut arrêter de dire que
les riches sont des gens mauvais non
c'est pas ce qu'on dit hein parce que en
vrai vous dites forcément le gamin on en
fait un petit con pour dire les drogués
les machins les bijoux c'est pas vrai le
gamin il peut avoir une montre
excusez-moi je suis pas la marque au
poignet et être très gentil très
généreux et avoir les les bases de la
ville les bases de la vie ça se repose
pas sur une application s'arrête pas moi
mon père quand même je reconnais ça
quand il manque il est avocat quand il
m'emmenait très très beau hôtel c'était
des chambres à 500 600000 € par par nuit
parfois chaque fois il venait il me dit
regarde comme c'est beau ce qu'il faut
travailler pour ça si t'as pas le bac si
tu travailles pas content c'est
exceptionnel là où tu es toi tes filles
elles ont fait tous les plus beaux
hôtels du monde elles vont là-dedans
comme dans un McDo absolument excuse-moi
ça empêche pas que mes filles ce sont
des filles gentils et généreuses et qui
ont conscience de la vie et de la dureté
du travail
qui sont équilibrées qui sont
intelligentes et qui ont le sens moi ma
fille quand elle voit des œufs dans la
rue je te jure elle prend l'argent mais
vraiment je l'ai vu faire ma fille la
dernière je la vois maman donne-moi des
sous je donne des sous elle les prend
des fois dans mon sac et elle va les
donner elle est ça veut rien dire tout
ça
[Musique]
mais heureusement qu'elle donne les
miens alors on sent Magalie je juge pas
et j'ai pas d'enfant et en plus j'ai vu
tes enfants ils sont très mignons je dis
juste il faut donner la valeur toi tu en
as une mémoire moi je partage pas du
tout la vie de Magalie donc voilà moi
j'ai quatre enfants ils sont élevés
comme je pense qu'il faut élever les
enfants moi j'ai une fille qui va être
avocate qui a 27 ans qui s'appelle
l'arabe j'embrasse ce soir elle emménage
un petit appartement de 30 m² là elle a
son petit studio elle veut mettre du
lino j'ai pas eu le lino évidemment fais
attention la pause 30 m² fait le bien
faire 300 balles de potes je le paye
mais regardez mais c'est papa mon copain
veulent poser c'est voilà c'est c'est
juste la différence et j'ai jamais
acheté et je n'achèterai jamais à mes
enfants une montre à deux trois millions
et même si j'ai eu beaucoup de moyens
j'ai jamais offert ça à mes enfants
parce que pour moi ça c'est avec ça
les valeurs du CAC 40 tu préfères je
m'excuse je préfère acheter une belle
montre à ma fille
une boule de claquer dans des conneries
comme dans la drogue par exemple
Magalie je te promets je t'adore plus je
suis désolé mais il met son fils en
danger évidemment que ma tante tout le
monde sait qu'il a une relation Nord
mais il va sortir dans la rue pauvre
gamin de garde du corps bébé
je suis désolé mais
lui sa femme tu te dis que effectivement
il y a un relatif manque de repère que
la dominante c'est l'argent et que tu
peux expliquer à quelqu'un que oui il a
beaucoup de choses mais que c'est un
privilège
du jour au lendemain mais dans tous les
cas il sera jamais dans la vraie vie
comme nous ce maintenant
quand j'ai eu mon permis c'était mon
rêve j'étais fou de voiture mon père m'a
dit tu bosses un mois je me suis acheté
une autobian qui que j'ai payé 1800
francs c'était ma voiture bof pour
l'avoir le fils Beckham il est
assis sur des millions d'euros sur un
mérite
jamais dans la vraie vie il sera jamais
dans la neige
s'il vous plaît qui a 16 ans
mais j'ai j'ai passé des vacances avec
eux en Grèce dans un hôtel si on était
dans un hôtel sublime tu as toujours une
vie toi j'ai animé sur M6
j'ai dirigé TF1 pendant 2 ans c'est vrai
la langue donc alors elle éduque il y
avait les enfants il y avait tous les
enfants qui étaient là et cetera et de
la fiancée du gant et franchement elle
éduque enfin les enfants à pas leur
disait de dire merci etc
non les enfants étaient extrêmement bien
élevés souriant gentil sympathique enfin
voilà donc il y a pas de problème
je vois pas le rapport entre avoir une
montre à 40000 et avoir une mauvaise
éducation si tu le vois pas pour moi
c'est un énorme problème on va passer un
autre sujet
le père peut très bien lui offrir la
montre en lui disant
vous êtes hors sol 40000 euros
[Musique]